monsieur bonsoir nous voici ce soir
encore en direct d'une capitale
étrangère toujours sur les marches du
pape mais cette fois ci à rebours après
varsovie en effet rome rome parce que
viennent de s'y dérouler des élections
capitales pour l'avenir du pays
des élections législatives anticipées et
vous savez que c'est un choix des
responsables de l'information d'antenne
2 d'essayer d'ouvrir un petit peu les
frontières de comparer les expériences
des uns et des autres et d'éviter la
tentation du chacun pour soi chacun chez
soi alors en deux mois le journal de 20h
s'est posées successivement chez nos
deux plus puissants voisins à hambourg
puis à londres récemment chez le tout
petit dernier de la communauté
européenne la grèce et donc ce soir en
italie l'italie qui nous regardent vous
savez avec toujours beaucoup de
sympathie car très nombreux sont les
italiens qui regardent antenne 2 chaque
soir et un pic que nous regardons nous
mêmes de notre côté avec beaucoup
d'amitié mais parfois un petit peu de
commisération nous disons c'est pauvre
italiens ils ne sont même pas gouverner
c'est un pays qui va à la dérive alors
nous allons essayer ce soir de regarder
les choses sans complaisance sans
indulgence
mais sans commisération non plus d'abord
l'italie ingouvernable c'est
malheureusement vrai et ça l'est
davantage encore depuis que nous
connaissons le verdict des urnes
verdict qui vient d'être officiellement
traduit il y à quelques heures à peine
alors je vous communique les chiffres
que je viens de recevoir la démocratie
chrétienne à 38,3 % elle perd un demi
pour cent elle faire un siège le parti
communiste 30 4%
il perd 4% à 26 sièges en tout le parti
socialiste 9 8%
il augmente le capital de 0 2%
le parti radical c'est la grosse
surprise 3 5%
il multiplie son score par trois il
arrive à 24 sièges
enfin le m et si le mouvement d'extrême
droite a perd cinq députés est à peu
près à 5,3 pour cent alors voilà les
chiffres
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire à la lecture
de tai chi d'utah vraiment le fait le
plus significatif c'est évidemment la
chute la défaite du parti communiste
allié
c'est d'autant plus étonnant que depuis
la libération les communistes ont
toujours progressé lors des élections
c'est pas une déroute quand même
puisqu'il reste à 1 2 puis de 30%
oui et le parti comme un citoyen pourra
toujours prétendre participer au pouvoir
avec la démocratie chrétienne alors la
démocratie chrétienne très grande
stabilité du corps électoral qui
d'ailleurs quand même étonnant parce que
après trente ans de gouvernement
démocrate chrétien les italiens presque
par un réflexe conditionné continue de
donner 38 ou 40 % la demande allemagne
lé problème vient du côté des petits
partis pas de grands changements il y à
un fait tout de même étonnant c'est la
victoire des sociaux-démocrates jeudi
étonnant parce que l'ancien secrétaire
de ce petit parti est en prison
actuellement il s'appelle tana ci et il
a été ministre de la défense pendant la
sphère lockheed
succès également mais qui était quand
même attendu du petit parti radical
le danger c'est que ce petit parti qui
était un mouvement contestataire devient
partie politiciens au même titre que les
autres
et bien tout cela nous le développons
tout à l'heure dans une dizaine de
minutes en images avec des enquêtes des
reportages sur place avec également un
débat qui opposera les différents
protagonistes de cet échiquier politique
et le temps que léon zitrone vous
développe les nouvelles parisienne
française et internationale nous allons
quitter le queens and nous le sommes
pour nous rendre au ministère de
l'intérieur à tout à l'heure
bien je vous rendrai patrick poivre
d'avor l'antenne tout à l'heure pour que
vous puissiez continuer ce journal en
direct
à quelques jours des élections
européennes une vive controverse a surgi
entre l'europe occidentale et les états
unis
principale raison les questions
d'énergie nous allons en parler tout au
long de ce journal au moment même où
l'europe est placé face à la pénurie
possible de pétrole l'amérique offre une
subvention spéciale à ses propres
importateurs monsieur françois poncet
ministre français des affaires
étrangères a demandé hier au président
carter d'annuler ces subventions
sinon l'europe serait dans une situation
difficile elle qui ne subventionne pas
ces importateurs refus de monsieur
carter demain à la maison blanche visite
du chancelier allemand helmut schmidt
indique monsieur françois poncet de
retour à paris verra son homologue à
monsieur guen cher en un mot ça bouge
donc il a été naturellement questions
d'énergie au cours de l'entretien que le
président giscard d'estaing a eu
aujourd'hui avec madame margaret
thatcher qui accomplit en france son
premier voyage officiel depuis qu'elle
est chef du gouvernement britannique
après le tête à tête les conversations
et d'argile de déjeuner à l'elysée et
une déclaration au micro
madame fait cher s'est rendu comme elle
l'avait demandé à l' usine nucléaire de
tricastin
pour sa première visite officielle à
l'étranger depuis qu'elle est devenue
premier ministre margaret thatcher avait
l'air très satisfaite de ses entretiens
avec valéry giscard d'estaing président
français mais aussi président en
exercice du conseil européen
j'ai clairement dit au président a
déclaré mr et mme thatcher que je tenais
beaucoup à maintenir d'excellentes
relations avec la france et à les
améliorer sans cesse j'ai également
clairement dit que nous étions très
attachés à l'idée europe et des
entretiens ont porté également sur l'a
fait qu'en particulier la rhodésie sur
la défense et surtout sur l'énergie
madame thatcher qui a visité cet après
midi une usine d'enrichissement
d'uranium du tricastin a affirmé que la
france premier pays européen à lancer un
programme nucléaire aiderait énormément
ses voisins à surmonter la crise du
vêtement je reviens à l'entretien de
monsieur françois penser avec le
président carter le ministre qui sera
l'invitée d'antenne de demain à 20
heures
nous en parlera un détail mais on sait
déjà que selon le président kerpert les
états unis de leur côté sont déçus
devant ce qu'ils appellent le manque de
soutien de la france au processus de
paix engagé au proche-orient leur
poulain nombreux passagère ou désaccords
profonds mais on a réellement
l'impression après une très longue lune
de miel lente dans les rapports entre la
france et les etats-unis ont de la
pression que les deux pays sont entrés
si vous voulez maintenant dans une phase
de désaccords profonds désaccords qui
porte vous savez sur les problèmes de
l'énergie sur les problèmes du pétrole
en particulier hier l'entretien entre
monsieur jean françois poncet le
président carter a duré à peine un quart
d'heure et jimmy carter a expliqué mêmes
justifier sa subvention de 5 dollars par
baril de pétrole importé aux états unis
mais surtout il semble que les états
unis est ouvertement reproché aux
français et aux européens pourquoi pas
leur hostilité systématique à leur
politique de paix américaine au proche
orient
c'est vrai que la france et vous le
savez a notamment toujours
critiquer sévèrement les efforts de
washington au proche orient et
l'argument des français a toujours été
de dire il ne peut pas y avoir de
règlement global ne peut y avoir que de
règlement global et non partiel comme
est en train de le faire depuis très
longtemps washington notamment après la
rencontre sadate bédié les américains
accusent en fait les européens
si vous voulez d'isoler le président
sadate dans le moyen orient et dans le
monde ce qui est très grave à leurs yeux
et en plus on sent ressurgir si vous
voulez les ont une sorte de politique
impérialiste des américains à savoir
messieurs les européens suivent et nous
suivez notre politique les yeux fermés
cette décision sur le pétrole prise sans
concertation avec les européens mais pas
la conséquence d'un simple geste d'un
simple sentiment de mauvaise humeur
non elle ne s'explique pas que pour des
raisons de mauvaise humeur ou par de la
rancune de la part des américains à
l'égard des européens et les français le
président carter doit retenir compte
aussi de son opinion publique intérieure
sa cote de popularité au plus bas ce
aussi et l'hiver aux états unis sera à
l'hiver prochain aux états unis sera
rude et surtout surtout à partir de
septembre prochain commence aux
etats-unis les premières primaires les
premières élections pour l'élection de
1981 les présidentielles de 80 et le
président carter compte bien se
représenter à la candidature à la maison
blanche
mais l'américain moyen que représente
pour lui l'europe at il seulement
conscience de nos difficultés
c'est l'un des thèmes de l'anc est mené
par notre représentant permanent à
washington jacques ces guides dans le
reportage que je vous invite à suit
c'était le 30 avril 1789 et c'est ici
que le premier président des états unis
george washington allait prêter serment
aujourd'hui les petits touristes
américains ne manquent jamais ce détour
historique leur pays soit une fédération
d'états ne les étonne pas mais quand on
leur parle de l'europe
quand distille jeff qui a 10 ans connaît
francfort baril et il pense que l'europe
c'est plus grand que les états unis et
cette approche assez vague de notre
continent est à mettre en parallèle avec
le détachement des hommes politiques les
hommes politiques américains
est ce qu'il croit la construction de
cette europe
ils sont un petit peu sceptique je
dirais ils y croient en principe mais
ils veulent voir que vraiment ça se fait
pourquoi pourquoi parce que en est
maintenant trente ans après la deuxième
guerre et après tout depuis la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
on parle toujours de la construction de
l'europe mais d'europe a énormément de
difficultés à se mettre ensemble
peut-on être européen à cette question
les américains des milieux d'affaires
répondent oui mais ajoutent-ils ne vous
faites pas d'illusions nous attendons de
cette europe qu'elle soit d'abord un
partenaire peut être un concurrent mais
surtout qu'elles représentent une force
véritable je crois qu'il souhaiterait
beaucoup avoir un partenaire quelque
chose qui soit leur taille et qui
permettent d'avoir trois grandes
puissances dans le monde
mais à l'heure actuelle il faut
reconnaître que les européens n'ont pas
fait preuve d'une très grande volonté de
créer leurs oeufs
ce qui aux yeux des américains doit
prendre deux formes d'une part une
monnaie commune parce qu'en réalité le
grand ciment des états unis celle
dollars signe s'il y avait 50 monnaie
différente dans les 50 états il n'y
aurait pas d' états unis et d'autre part
un gouvernement fédéral dans le genre de
celui doit-il tard un parlement comme
elle est une monnaie commune deux
éléments qui sont déjà en place qui
pourrait modifier les rapports entre
l'europe et les états unis et une
évolution à laquelle les milieux
d'affaires américains sont favorables
certes mais en posant aussi cette
question quelle europe nous prépare t
monsieur mitterrand au cours d'une
conférence de presse à déplorer la
faiblesse de l'europe devant les états
unis
il aurait voulu que monsieur françois
poncet s'exprimant au nom de l'europe
dans son ensemble et non pas que
l'outaouais sington des porte-paroles
successifs monsieur mitterrand a
regretté le manque de concertation at il
dit au sein de l'europe une europe qui
l'aurait voulu cohérente et homogène
pour discuter d'égal à égal avec
washington
il avait auparavant présenté le comité
national de soutien à la liste
socialiste pour les élections
européennes de dimanche
et parmi les membres de ce comité des
personnalités du monde des arts des
lettres du spectacle de la politique
vous requins et raies sur ces images
annie girardot et chats roussillon
l'ancien dirigeant communiste côtés de
monsieur me taire voici donc un extrait
de sa conférence de presse
donc nous réclamons plus d'europe
dans ce domaine et non pas moins que le
président capteurs et reçu un quart
d'heure seulement le ministre des
affaires étrangères française j'ai
écouté cette nouvelle comme ça je dois
dire qu'il me fait mal au coeur
nous a fait mal au coeur c'est vraiment
un type de relation comme si la liste
est ici puis sont souveraines est hélas
des clients pas acceptable et j'espère
bien que ce ne sera pas acceptée par le
gouvernement français alors j'ai une
dépêche afp qui me dit que monsieur
giraud ministre français de l'industrie
chargée des questions d'énergie a été
reçu par monsieur chez singer secrétaire
d'état de l'énergie c'est à dire son
homologue américain et monsieur giraud a
été reçu en sa qualité de président en
exercice des ministres de la communauté
économique européenne il a élevé une
protestation auprès de monsieur saisine
gère à propos de la décision de
subventions prises par les états unis et
dans l'entourage du ministre français on
souligne que cette prestation
communautaire est importante car c'est
la première fois que la cee manifeste
solidarité envers les états unis sur les
problèmes énergétiques
la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale vient
d'entendre monsieur bourges ministre de
la défense et monsieur bourges a dit que
le niveau technologique de l'armement
nucléaire français sera comparable en
1985 aux armements détenu actuellement
tant par les américains que par les
soviétiques par ailleurs pour monsieur
vivien président de cette commission des
finances la protection des populations
civiles face aux agressions éventuelle
d'une puissance étrangère constitue une
préoccupation de cette commission
alors pour l'un des commissaires
monsieur royer seule une protection
minimum de la population peut rendre
pleinement crédible notre forces
nucléaires stratégiques par ailleurs
d'après le ministère de l'équipement
le coût de l'aménagement des caves des
parkings pour en faire des abris
convenable représenterait entre 2 et 10
% du coût des constructions 9 3e journée
du voyage du pape en pologne r il y
avait décerné à czestochowa la plus
haute distinction du vatican la rose
d'or au cardinal primat de pologne me
sonia rubinsky demain il célébrera la
messe dans l'ancien camp de
concentration d'auschwitz et vous la
verrez en direct sur 1,22 à 16 heures ce
sera un reportage émouvant
aujourd'hui le pape a passé une matinée
moins chargées ou un estérias magora
avant d'assister à la conférence de
l'épiscopat polonais le résumé de la
journée par nos envoyés spéciaux
après l'accueil triomphal qu'il vient de
vivre ces trois derniers jours dans sa
pologne natale le pape jean paul ii qui
est toujours à czestochowa qu'il
quittera demain soir pau traque aux vies
le pape a eu une journée un peu plus
calme si l'on peut dire puisqu'il a
présidé la conférence extraordinaire des
évêques polonais il a évoqué avec eux le
problème des rapports de l'église et de
l'état
un peu plus tard il a prononcé le
discours que tout le monde attendait une
remarque en passant le service d'ordre
quelque peu anarchique hier est
sérieusement renforcer l'axé la tribune
papale interdite jean paul ii a donc
lancé un appel pressant à la
normalisation des rapports entre
l'église et l'état en pologne sur la
base du respect des droits de l'homme et
celui de la liberté religieuse a dit le
pape
mais on a bien compris que même si
l'église est disposée au dialogue avec
l'état communiste
elle lui reste opposé sur le fond aucune
réconciliation n'est possible alors on
respecte
le statut pro faute de mieux la messe à
auschwitz et pour le jeudi 7 je me suis
trompé d'âge
monsieur michel l'ondaine ambassadeur de
france à san salvador est rentré ce
matin à paris durant quatre semaines
elle a été l'otage dans son ambassade
avec cinq de ses collaborateurs du bloc
populaire révolutionnaire du salvador
dès sa descente d'avion à paris le
diplomate français apparemment reposer
accompagné de son épouse et de monsieur
cuvillier du quai d'orsay négociateurs
français à san salvador a été accueilli
par le docteur dur frère médecin au
ministère des affaires étrangères
l'ambassadeur paraissait détendu et
soulagé
naturellement après des cinq semaines
difficiles qu'il a vécu là-bas en corse
avant l'ouverture le jeudi 14 juin
devant la cour de sûreté de l'état du
procès de 21 militants du front de
libération de la corse
le ton monte manifestation de soutien à
bastia aux emprisonnés et surtout des
heurts violents
ajaccio entre jeunes manifestants et les
crs il y a eu plusieurs blessés parmi
les forces de l'ordre
des affrontements d'une extrême violence
en effet hier soir ajaccio 200 jeunes
gens armés de barres de fer deux fusils
de chasse ont attaqué le cantonnement
d'une compagnie de crs en plein centre
de la ville les manifestants comme il
l'avait fait 24 heures auparavant ont
lancé des cocktails molotov et tiré en
direction des crs
l'affrontement a duré plusieurs heures
il a fallu l'intervention des gardes
mobiles pour disperser les assaillants
bilan de crs et de gardes mobiles
blessés et une dizaine de jeunes gens
interpellés puis relâchés dans la nuit
cet affrontement semble-t-il est
l'aboutissement d'un incident survenu il
ya quelques jours un crs avait été prise
à partie par plusieurs jeunes gens à la
sortie d'un cinéma et dimanche soir des
crs en civil reconnaissait dans ce café
l'auteur de cette agression
l'interpellation avait alors donné lieu
à une première échauffourée
après ces incidents le climat risque de
s'alourdir d'ici le 14 juin date du
procès devant la cour de sûreté de
l'état de 21 membres du front de
libération de la corse tennis
internationaux de france à roland garros
tout va bien on board a éliminé en
quarts de finale le chilien et games
master en trois sets 6 4 6 1 7 5
d'autre part gerulaitis a battu
l'espagnol et guerras en quatre sets
et ce matin l'argentin vilas avait battu
l'américain mayer en cinq sets le
lendemain ne s'améliorera pas beaucoup
il sera couvert avec des orages mais
l'heure est venue de rendre l'antenne
maintenant à patrick poivre d'arvor
attention à vos robes à bout eh bien
nous voici donc à rome nous avons eu le
temps de quitter le cul rénale sur la
présidence de république pour nous
rendre au ministère de l'intérieur
l'endroit où sont comptabilisés et tous
les résultats derrière moi vous le voyez
dans une ambiance assez fébrile faut
dire aussi que c'est l'un des endroits
les plus protégés dû montrer patte
blanche pour y accéder on a évidemment
toujours peur ici à rome du terrorisme
alors je dire que tous mes confrères
italiens s'interrogent un petit peu sur
la portée de ce scrutin d'hier et
d'avant-hier il messaggero par exemple
se contentent simplement d'annoncer les
résultats sans titre explicatif
résistera qui est assez proche du parti
communiste se contente de dire voici et
quelle est la couleur du nouveau
parlement sans explication non plus la
république à la repubblica voit la
victoire du centre à travers ces
élections on peut en discuter on va en
discuter d'ailleurs tout à l'heure et
enfin il popolo qui est l'organe de la
démocratie chrétienne se contente de
donner le chiffre qui est assez
impressionnant 14 millions de votants le
chiffre des votants donc pour les
démocrates chrétiens
c'est moins que rien qui sont
représentés d'ailleurs autour de cette
table par monsieur ado de paulhe qui est
député qui vient d'être réélu
monsieur marco pannella qui est à ma
droite et
leur disons du parti radical il vient
d'être élu également en revanche pas de
représentants communistes il avait dit
oui ils ont fini par dire non on peut
peut-être s'étonner de cette absence du
parti communiste aujourd'hui peut-être
justifiée par un chiffre assez médiocre
alors évidemment on va essayer de
dépasser un petit peu ces considérations
de politique intérieure italienne pour
vous demander monsieur de paille qui va
gouverner après c'est une nouvelle
élection nous jour quoique
il ya eu un renforcement au point de vue
de la force de députés du centre que
naturellement la démocratie chrétienne
vais maintenir et qu'ils puissent parler
avec un parti socialiste auquel nous
voulons donner des conditions très
favorables
donc vous voulez plutôt un gouvernement
de centre gauche et pas de soutien
communiste d'un gouvernement de centre
gauche si on peut re utiliser la formule
qui tiennent compte des expériences et
parfois à des amères l'espérience du
centre gauche
évidemment nous sommes les empêcheurs de
tourner en rond dans cette situation on
se laisse pas trop maintenant prendre
part le scénario de cette comédie qui
hélas n'est pas du tout de la rdt mais
qui d'une commune comme aide est
absolument regret en réalité les
communistes des démocrates chrétiens se
disputent comme des complices autour
d'un buteur du butin que je nourris donc
pour vous c'est blanc bonnet bonnet
blanc absolument et vous êtes d'accord
sur l'otan
vous êtes d'accord sur le nucléaire vous
êtes d'accord sur le concordat entre
l'église et vous êtes d'accord sur
l'ordre public
vous êtes d'accord sur la politique la
justice et donc votre problème
ainsi que le problème des communistes
c'est au contraire de continuer à faire
penser aux italiens que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord pour pouvoir occuper toute la
scène politique déterminée en détaille
justement ce que seront les problèmes
que va rencontrer l'italie dans les
années à venir de voir à travers
l'exemple de naples ce qu'est
l'ingouvernabilité non pas d'un pays
mais d'une ville
vous allez le voir dans ce reportage
paralysé pour nous patricia charnolé
annappes ville symbole de tous les maux
italien le parti radical a choisi de
dénoncer le laxisme politique et la
justice sociale avec cinquante militants
seulement il réunit ce jour là près de
7000 personnes sur la grande place des
rois à la tribune maria antonieta macho
qui candidate pour les élections
européennes
il ya dix ans elle était députée
communiste de n'a pas exclu du parti peu
après elle revient aujourd'hui dans sa
ville les condamner la gestion depuis
trois ans le parti communiste est à la
tête de la municipalité
il gère difficilement le déficit
chronique de la ville c'est une bien
lourde tâche de régler en quelques mois
les problèmes que la démocratie
chrétienne a ignoré pendant 30 ans mais
ici rien n'a changé ou presque rien
la grande bataille de la municipalité
prendre la ville propre ne procure pas
d'emploi on compte toujours 190 mille
chômeurs pour une population active de
300000 personnes la moitié des habitants
vivent avec en moyenne 300 francs par
mois rien n'a changé non plus dans
l'intensité des contrastes sur les
collines nappe continue à enfanter des
quartiers luxueux sont mahler est aussi
grand que sa beauté et ses malades caché
à l'intérieur de cette ville que vous
filmez dans son ventre
c'était mal être qui
au jour le jour qui est allé sous les
journaux mais auquel tout le monde
s'habitue ce sont les enfants qui
meurent depuis deux nuits l'épidémie est
endémique
ce sont les rares qui dévore une vieille
femme qui dévorent des enfants et donc
c'est toujours c'est à bin qui est en
train d'autres détruire complètement et
en même temps qu'ils résistent dans les
ciels de la mer de la portée de certains
endroits
la spéculation immobilière et dc
fleurissant un appartement coûte plus
d'un million de francs la pauvreté on la
trouve en bar dans le ventre de la ville
dans ses bassines arrière-cour sans
lumière vie le petit peuple de naples le
popoli nos comme on l'appelle ici
ici il y a deux semaines une femme est
morte dévorée par les rats ici aussi un
enfant de moins d'un an meurt toutes les
20 minutes alors à cet avocat et un
militant du parti radical
on explique qu'on ne sais vraiment pas
comment changer cette vie car tout le
problème est là
ces hommes et ces femmes sont persuadés
que rien ne peut se faire une s'obtenir
sans intervention d'un homme politique
un certificat de naissance
on ne demande pas la mairie nos députés
celui-ci l'obtient alors on vote pour
yolande le fataliste napolitain est un
bon terrain pour ses vieilles pratiques
clientèle air il existe ainsi un modus
vivendi qui profite à tout le monde à
cause de cela tout est permis
regardez bien nous sommes ici dans le
quartier des voleurs en plein centre de
naples
la police nous pénètre presque jamais
soixante dix mille personnes vivent de
la contrebande notamment des cigarettes
dans l'illégalité n'étonne plus personne
pourtant même ici on aimerait bien que
cela change que ce père et vous des
élections
moi je ne sais pas les partis politiques
vous savez je n'y connais rien qu'est ce
qu'il veut qu'est ce qui te demande tu
veux qu'on vote pour lui
vous voulez des cigarettes achetées moi
mes cigarettes monsieur et l'europe
est ce que vous en pensez l'europe oui
d'accord mais il faut que ça change
aussi
il faudra déjà honnête
même pour les voleurs l'honnêteté
politique est aujourd'hui une
revendication c'est sur ce changement de
mentalité que joue le parti radical les
jeunes ils ont la volonté de changer il
nous dit on semble mais une folie d'y
aider il faut leur expliquer qu'ils ne
doivent plus se comporter comme des
éternels assistés
il faudrait aussi que les enfants
aillent à l'école comme envoyer les
enfants à l'école
alors que la plupart travaillent pour 5
francs par jour un salaire nécessaire à
la vie toute la famille comment donner
des droits ce sous prolétariat qui viaur
lannoy en travaillant au noir à domicile
alors ne parti radical pense aujourd'hui
que c'est un problème qui dépasse la
réalité italienne et qui finalement
concerne toute l'europe
voilà presque exemple je crois assez
probant de ce qui se passe dans une
municipalité assez tiraillé ne l'ont été
de voir un petit peu quels sont les
problèmes auxquels va faire face
l'italie maintenant avec tout d'abord
monsieur de police l'homme de problèmes
économiques
j'ai regardé les chiffres du chômage
plus d'un million six cent mille
chômeurs ceux de l'est des prix à la
consommation 1,9 pour cent en janvier
1,5 en février à 1,2 en mars 1,1 en
avril
vous allez vers une inflation galopante
alors comment est ce que vous allez vous
y prendre mais le problème du chômage
surtout celui de la jeunesse est un
problème car mais on peut pas les
résoudre seulement avec des lois qui
sont assez conjoncturels comme celui
pour le chômage de la jeunesse et il
faut reprendre absolument une politique
de productivité qu'ils puissent élargir
notre système de production dans
lesquelles le force de jeunes puissent
trouver normalement directement
spontanément une place de travail à
travers
l'amplification de ce système et pour ce
qui concerne au contraire le problème de
l'inflation qui nous inquiète et qui est
le premier point que nous trouverons à
résoudre il faudra commencer à retrouver
un contrôle sur la dépense publique qui
soient plus sévères il faudra que le
parlement se saisisse de la dépense
publique sur tout il faudra éliminer
toute une série d'automatismes qui sont
dangereux et et qui parfois a voulu par
les syndicats parfois accepter par le
patronat ont limité d'une et de l'autre
côté les possibilités de dialectique ce
qu'ils avaient dans les systèmes alors
je crois que ce sont deux points qu'il
faut aborder avec des mesures assez
décidé sans savoir faire peur d'être
impopulaire car et pourtant vous êtes au
pouvoir depuis trente ans quand même
oui l'idée mais c'est naturellement
naturellement ce sont des choses qu'on
voit dans les autres systèmes également
et il faut voir comment les autres
forces politiques et les nous ne sommes
pas la majorité absolue ou le savez bien
le problème monsieur panella et celui-là
vous concerne peut-être très directement
car vous êtes assez populaire dans les
milieux disons très jeune c'est le
problème de la violence du terrorisme
on a vu que rien n'a été réglé même si
la campagne électorale n'a pas été très
entachée et coupé d'ailleurs j'ai
certains tout le monde un certain que
c'est dans ce ministère où on agit
certainement des tenants du terrorisme
et du pire des terrorismes dans le
ministère de la justice aussi dans nos
services secrets aussi c'est prouvé
c'est à dire voulait dire que là je veux
dire que ici les certainement des chefs
de terrorisme en italie
la gamme dacia est courante et tout le
monde reconnaît que c'est tout
simplement la vérité que
il ya eu il y à des procès que l'on fait
pas depuis huit ans ou 9 ans ou des
généraux les plus prestigieux de notre
de notre état on était même arrêté on ne
vais pas depuis huit ans ce procès est
le parti communiste parti fasciste la
démocratie chrétienne les socialistes
sont tous d'accord pour que les gens ou
dit que ce procès n'ait pas fait
pourquoi j'arrêterai évidemment ce débat
car je voudrais d'abord mettre un
troisième problème auquel on va voir
dans un sujet qui a réalisé pour nos
bernard benyamin un sujet sur la
condition des femmes en italie est un
sujet qui débouche très rapidement vous
allez voir sur le problème de
l'avortement
les femmes ont beaucoup changé comme
sentiment de soi même des sentiments
vers la famille par exemple l'idée de
l'autorité du mari ou du père et a été
complètement mis en discussion mais
sinon beaucoup de ces sentiments de
l'indépendance peut pas être mis en
pratique à cause de la difficulté par
exemple de trouver de travail femmes ne
trouvent pas de travail
et c'est ya du chômage aussi pour les
hommes pour les femmes c'est encore pire
et si on trouve de travail ces détails
très mal payés très multi fiant très
difficile alors très souvent le faire
encore aujourd'hui n'ont pas
d'alternative que le mariage c'est à
dire encore aujourd'hui une femme pour
sortir de la famille de d'origine de la
famille du père de la mère doit sait
manier ce qu'elle peut pas être
indépendant même selanne travail vous
voyez il ya cette contradiction entre
l'indépendance des zones de culture des
consciences et l'indépendance économique
et c'est vrai que la femme italienne est
prise dans les contradictions du système
et de la société de son pays
l'exemple le plus significatif concerne
sans aucun doute l'avortement
il est légal en italie la loi et même
plus libérale qu'en france le problème
c'est que 75 % des médecins refusent de
le pratiquer par conviction religieuse
mais d'abord qu'en pensent les
principaux intéressés les italiennes
l'avortement n'est pas une chose jusque
c'est pour les pauvres filles fermées
les jo pour moi c'est juste et pour moi
aussi moi personnellement ça ne
m'intéresse pas peut-être en les jeunes
c'est bien moi je suis pour
parce que les gens ne savent pas encore
comment ne pas faire d'enfant
tant que les gens n'auront pas pris
conscience de ça il faudra avorter comme
on fait ton sinon on ne va pas voir 14
ou 15 enfants je suis favorable parce
que je suis pour la possibilité de
choisir celles qui veulent le fond
celles qui ne veulent pas ne le ferai
pas c'est clair non c'est comme pour le
divorce
je suis contre pourquoi parce que je
suis contre
derrière l'un de ces masques de
tragédienne il y a moïse à elle a 21 ans
demain elle a décidé d'aller à l'hôpital
san giacomo à rome pour se faire avorter
elle travaille dans un théâtre très
particulier un théâtre de femmes ici les
pièces ont décrit de jouer mise en scène
par des familles si le machiniste est
une femme
autant dire que c'est l'avant garde
romaine qui se retrouvent dans ce
théâtre de la magdalena
mais c'est précisément parce que moi ira
est une féministe convaincue qu'elle a
tenu à ce que nous l'accompagnons à
l'hôpital le lendemain matin
mozilla est bien entré à l'hôpital quant
à nous il est des situations où la
caméra est indésirable
ici vous êtes en italie m'a même dit
l'une de ces femmes qui allaient se
faire avorter avant de nous prier
fermement de sortir
son chef s'est il passé il se passe que
je suis venu pour une interruption de
grossesse mais il n'y a plus de place
ils en feront seulement 4 tous les trois
jours
quatre personnes et les personnes sont
déjà là depuis la nuit dernière à 2
heures du matin alors s'ils prennent 12
personnes par semaine le lundi le
mercredi et le samedi
ça veut dire que je dois revenir ici
vendredi soir passé toute la nuit ici et
la matinée du sommeil pour avoir une
petite chance j'ai parlé à des clips des
femmes à l'intérieur et elle m'a dit
qu'elle était là depuis hier après midi
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire alors je
ne sais pas je ne s'y plie voilà en un
petit quart d'heure nous avons essayé
d'être le plus complet possible sur un
pays voisin et ami en l'occurrence
l'italie j'espère que vous en savez un
petit peu plus sur les italiens
aujourd'hui que vous avez peut-être
compris à travers le tempérament très
latin des différents intervenants qui
sont ils ont participé à cette émission
qu'elle pouvait être donc les problèmes
qu'elles rencontraient et peut-être
qu'elle amplifié voilà nous dit-on
maintenant donc les jardins du ministère
de l'intérieur
nous regagnons paris s'éveille heure de
paris que j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain à demain